[Music]
my family
gathering of six or more is coming back
on me thanksgiving
you've got the corona i shouldn't say it
in front of my lawyer
no but i'm a serial felon because
i had nana and i had mama
and just consider it uh just considered
a house in a mexican neighborhood with
19 cars in the driveway
your christmas card is evidence yes
exhibit a making jolly and mary
we did but we'll get tested now a felony
and uh
we have a lot to talk about today by the
way i may have voted twice
and if you want to lose all hope for
humanity just read the at replies to
when i tweeted this people
just wait to the show never really
going to show receipts i am going to
show you
my wife's registration her vote which
she did absentee my grandmother and
myself
two different states despite a formal
change of address so we're going to get
into that we're going to be talking
about the new
lawsuit's not new but thanksgiving we've
both read about 200 pages of
affidavits uh briefs you read much more
than 200 pages
did i i don't remember i didn't really
have the same thanksgiving that you
passed out and woke up later
past the cranberry i need to read uh i
need to somehow
find out how to read these symbols that
are apparently written in papyrus
because the brief was i don't know i
guess sydney powell didn't have a space
bar but i don't want to detract
from the message uh we're talking about
that we will be talking about
uh tucker carlson and whether he is
friend or foe i know there have been a
lot of sort of uh
a lot of chirp a lot of chirping from
people a little bit
just to the twitter i don't want to give
them a plug but um you always say that
my half asian lawyer bill richmond is
here how are you hey great
did you have a good thanksgiving i did
do you guys eat turkey oh yeah
peeking duck oh yeah all sides mexican
side the chinese side the
cracker side yeah we all love turkey and
your wife does not look mexican at all
yeah she looks very much more like she
looks like jasmine princess jasmine very
much so
yes very much she doesn't have the mc
hammer pants very often no no
but when she does right and when she
gets the tiger out man plus she's
allowed to
drive goodness yeah uh my uh producer
quarter black carrot is here let's go
with gerald a how are you good
thanksgiving well yes very good thank
you audio wait tokunawan is here and by
the way people who are watching right
now
right now the many click like we're
running some a b
testing on youtube seeing if likes or
comments
result in this uh appearing in your
notification your subscription feed so
everyone right now who's watching
whether you're watching live or archive
please just click like
do it um we have a lot of news to get to
first off i'm sure you guys have read
about this joe biden um
had a hairline fracture in his foot
playing with his
his dog um and uh of course listen
obviously i think this is probably one
of the greatest frauds perpetrated in
the american public with the vote but it
doesn't mean that i want joe biden to
twist an angle
sure um and unfortunately we do have
exclusive footage of the incident
[Music]
i don't know what you don't yeah i mean
just run the actuary tables you know
he's not going to make it very
long hey dog like major look even major
is doing his part for the american
people here
right yeah i like major he's a good guy
you know maybe not completely effective
but he's still working at it
the love of a dog can sweep one off
their feet isn't that right joe lewis
yep okay uh and by the way another
another big thing for joe biden before i
move on to uh
why this really is likely untrue uh the
media is reporting that he finally
crossed
across the 80 million threshold that's
the largest turnout
wow in american election history which
makes sense because
you know look at his social media
following yeah and uh how many times
he's he he is the most beloved president
ever so much enthusiasm yeah his
enthusiasm gap was
very you know what guys we got to say we
have to call it that we were wrong here
obviously because yeah we made fun of
him for all of those lids yeah i mean
monday
yeah tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday sunday at the time
plus they have no traction i don't care
how they market the waffle grip that's
why major took you off your feet joe
biden um
but he did cross the 80 million
threshold and we actually do
uh go now live to his celebration uh at
the biden
campaign headquarters
[Music]
listen i'm not going to throw stones on
someone being married because i did it
this weekend yeah dude
the one in the pigtails was actually the
kovitzar oh yeah
it was true my cousin's wang and chang
man they know how to drop
a beat that's disgusting everybody
corona tonight so
um by the way follow me on instagram
here we're going to be moving along the
trail if you uh are not following me
louder with crowder on instagram
of course we'll be taking your live chat
after this playing hipster hobo on mug
club exclusive
that's an oldie what a good idea do you
consider joining up loudwicker.com my
question to you right now off the bat is
what do you think is the most egregious
example of
of the i don't want to say election part
the election shenanigans at this point
do you think it's the dominion software
issue that people have talked about
do you think it's sending poll workers
home um and
and not allowing them to observe do you
think it's the out-of-state ballots do
you think it's that what do you think is
the example
that is most definitive that matters
most what do you think will end up in
any of these uh situations being
being thrown out i guess uh kind of
right off the bat uh i think i think
georgia might flip
we spent a long time going through the
georgia brief and michigan georgia 104
pages michigan was
75 and that's just the briefs including
the affidavits the analysis
right the uh a lot of a lot of stuff
there and before we get to that
michigan and georgia uh let me start
with a little a little personal anecdote
so yeah little michigan
on a hunch
[Music]
i find out this weekend
and a hunch your honor that i was
registered to vote in two different
states
really despite the fact that i did vote
i did vote in one state and i had a
formal change of address
my wife voted absentee and there's a way
to track absentee yeah
we'll get into that uh apparently she
did not vote absentee now i will allow
there's maybe a 99
chance that this is all an accident
including by the way with my grandmother
96-year-old grandmother who you saw at
the michigan rally who also voted
absentee
but the system shows that she did not
vote absentee
so um this is a little disturbing we
have some phone calls to make follow up
on but i will i will grant you i could
be wrong about all of it and it's just a
system error in which case don't worry
about it because it's just the largest
most pivotal election in american
history
[Laughter]
the system works you saw your granny
coming to biology yes
my 96 year old grandma 97 year old
grandmother is playing 4d
chess she's got them right where she
wants them
she's awesome
go play checkers and give my money to
those chinamen
it's chess so uh they started wanting to
check the status of my wife's absentee
vote because there's a lot going around
where they're saying a lot of
you hear this rhetoric that many
millions of americans believe that their
vote did not count right
and i go well hold on a second we've
checked public voting records before at
least for previous elections that's not
too hard to do it should be pretty easy
to find out if my vote counted if my
wife's vote counted some states don't
give you the ability to track your vote
just your registration some states do
give you the ability
to track your vote if you voted absentee
um assuming the post office works so
again we're making some leaps here yeah
it's a big assumption give us a minute
look before you post office so um
some states do michigan is one of them
michigan is one state that does give you
the ability to track your absentee
ballot
okay but i don't want you to take my
word for it go to clip
two the most important tool that people
need to know about
is really the michigan voter information
center which can be found at
michigan.gov
vote there's a service that's run by the
secretary of state bureau of elections
and on that you can find uh if you're
registered your registration status
where you vote at
the contact information for your local
clerk on that if you have voted absentee
you can see the date that your
request was received by your local clerk
when your ballot was mailed out
when they received it so that's a great
tool to kind of hold the clerk
accountable
and to make sure that you know that
you're where your vote is at
in the process sorry clerks hope you
have an answering machine
because i will encourage everybody to
check this out and if you have the same
anomalies that i found with every person
i know who voted absentee in michigan
i would encourage you to call your
clerks and go through the process let me
explain to you two really quickly
this is how that is supposed to look we
have a video you can keep my mic on look
you go to the website
yeah uh and then you have an area where
you track your registration
you go you hit your registration and you
type in your information
and then if you have already voted
absentee this will show you right here
what turns up for people who are
listening on audio
right here we uh uh well this is
actually this is the wrong one i think
we have uh we have clip three first
before that quarter black carrots this
is clip three
three three this is clip three okay but
that's my wife
and it did not so there it says that
she's registered but there's an actual
clip
here uh that should show what it should
look like that uh reg sent in
uh if not you can bring it up steve
gibbons really quickly so that was my
wife
who did vote absentee so you look at
that and you say okay well that shows
that she's
registered yes look the system's working
but my wife voted no further
already so this is not to check and see
if you're registered
this is supposed to be uh an ability to
track your ballot do we have that token
on where we can bring that up
from reg where we have a video that
actually shows what it looks like if
someone has voted absentee
and you should be able to track we're
pulling it up now okay yeah well i need
that really uh
really quickly warped because that's
kind of pivotal here
and it should have been in the show uh
um so
uh for record my wife did vote absentee
michigan yeah for record i did not
okay also my grandmother my 96 year old
grandma that we can bring this up as an
overlay she did as well you saw at the
michigan rally let's bring that up just
as an overlay so you guys can see it
this is my grandmother
um there you go so it says
congratulations you are registered
good that's fantastic that's great but
it doesn't say that
you voted or the progress on your vote
right let's show that uh clip if we have
it
that uh reg's the bandit sent do we have
it here of
what it looks like we don't have it of
what it looks like if you actually voted
it will show you the progress we'll go
back to it show you the progress
of your absentee ballot usually with
some kind of tracking info
as well right is this about as good as
like when i'm tracking an amazon package
and it says that it arrived but really
it's just no another office private
private industry far more effective
so it only says that they were
registered to vote we'll get that video
up here in a second
uh now to be clear i voted in texas
okay okay we can show this right here i
voted in texas quarterback
pay yeah we do have the michigan okay
now before we go to my vote this is what
it should look like and we'll just go
through this all the way again so people
can see it
in sequential order because i don't want
anyone to have any
reason to doubt this this is what it
should look like if you go to that
website
and you vote uh or sorry and you voted
absentee and it tracks
your address audio wait it looks like
you're panic over there we have it so
do you would you like the video first or
your personal registration
let's show the video first if you vote
in michigan you voted absentee this is
what it should look like keep my mic on
let's show what it looks like and here
is the video
if you okay how to track your michigan
absentee ballot there you go right here
on youtube
okay michigan.gov looks like what we did
okay are you registered you enter in
your information to show if you are
registered
uh and if you vote by mail this is the
video right here
it shows you okay entering in your
birthday you can enter in your month
then you enter your birth date you don't
need the exact day you just need the
year
and then you enter in your zip code now
this should show you look
you were registered and it should show
you the status of your absentee
vote see that right there with a
tracking number
yeah let's bring up really quickly we
can uh i don't know if we can warp speed
again so people can see
my wife voted absentee in michigan this
is what she got when she
signed up there you go exact same
process we entered in the proper
information
she is registered to vote in michigan i
know some of you said well because we uh
have a
house in michigan we've had some family
members in ill health my wife has been
in michigan for
a lot quite a few months out of the year
before i uh other than me this year so
here we go we entered in her information
i'm going to block it because she is
married
uh so you don't see all of her
information uh here you go
now we enter it in zip code process yeah
you are registered okay but
no other information what else she voted
absolutely by the way she's not a
democrat she voted well ahead of the
deadline for the election
since it shows i'm like i don't know
same week good enough
now i thought maybe that's just an
anomaly my grandmother is 97 someone who
is
actually at risk right plus it's just a
trek she's got to go down to a grade
school
so let's bring that up again my
grandmother ruth 97 years old
here is nope just says you're registered
no status
on absentee vote no other now to yours
truly on a hunch
i voted in texas because i did not spend
nearly as much time in michigan here so
uh i had a formal change of address
voted in texas let's show this really
quickly this is proof of me
voting in texas i'm registered to vote
in texas
formal change of address i'm obviously
on file there here's something else
interesting
i'm also registered to vote in michigan
hmm
bring it up to quarterback yeah okay
well
let's let's bring this up there's uh we
that's right there you go
i am registered to vote in michigan now
that may not seem in and of itself
disturbing enough though i would argue
it is
yeah let's bring this up from forbes
michigan's law
is that everybody who's registered to
vote gets a ballot they don't have to be
requested this was signed into law
anyone registered to vote
gets a ballot so someone living at that
address
where i no longer live this is an old
residence right received my ballot as to
whether they voted
i do not know all i know is my wife
voted in michigan my wife voted absentee
my grandmother voted absentee who lives
in michigan
100 of the days of the year and the
information that we have on their
absentee vote
is the exact same information we have on
my voter registration in michigan
which is false so best case scenario
this is a broken system where you cannot
check
the status of your absentee ballot worst
case scenario it's the perfect system
to try and remove any transparency for
obvious fraud right
right and we'll be making some calls to
clerks i want everyone who voted
absentee in michigan
uh everyone who voted absentee period if
you have a state and there's a database
we'll have it up at loud earthquaker.com
where you can check in your state if you
have the ability to track your absentee
vote not everyone does michigan you do
there's more than just my wife and
grandmother by the way in case you're a
wine of dude
there's a little bit of 90 chess here
we're still looking into it
what it does is it really highlights a
problem that people had already
identified weeks and months ahead of
time
which was if you move to a mandatory
sending
of absentee ballots to all registered
voters
it completely ignores the fact that
those systems and logs typically
lag months or quarters behind people
moving
their address changes dying that kind of
thing and while certainly there are
systems in place to check those things
but if you combine a rush to count them
all i mean in a normal election you
would have a smaller number of issues
have a smaller number to check
but there really aren't any systems for
michigan to check this right now and now
they have nothing
and yet i changed my address formally i
clearly voted in a different state
i don't live there right well the
systems don't talk i mean the system in
texas doesn't talk to the system in
michigan oh
it seems like that should be necessary
in a federal election you would think so
that's not there it seems like it should
be as proficient as when i used to play
bolo in the computer science lab in the
sixth grade
on lan i feel like we're stuck in like
you know aol online stuff like
really we don't have a system where you
can change the address yeah i bet you
that the federal government has net
zero addresses yes not a one
and they make calls from vonage now
people say you want to disenfranchise
voters now by throwing
hold on a second i don't know if my vote
my wife doesn't know her vote counted
my 97 year old grandmother she probably
doesn't have any votes left
maybe she might get a midterm in there
if she's lucky
we don't know if her vote counted so
this is what i'm saying unless it's
legal unless it's constitutional you
have to throw them out
you have to throw them out if you cannot
know that every legal vote is counted
because right now we are in a system
where illegal votes are absolutely
counted and we'll get into the
the documents we'll get into the briefs
here and the affidavits yep and we don't
know if legal votes are counted there's
no way to track it
there's no way to attract either and
that's disenfranchising you you also
have a right to make sure that your vote
not only counts but is not deluded
right illegal votes for whatever reason
mistakes can happen where you send
ballots out to people who shouldn't get
them they've moved whatever happens
right so
and people can be you know bad actors
they right fill out your ballot and send
it in and say aha
democrat i tell you what if someone
actually voted
in michigan for me i'm gonna be i'm
going to be upset that would be funny
no i'm not gonna lie i'm gonna laugh i
would do but then
they voted too keep in mind too the
recounts didn't check signatures because
there's a secrecy there's a secrecy
envelope there's the ballot right they
didn't check they just recounted the
numbers in the machines which is a
marvel to me
that georgia found 5500 votes without
actually auditing or checking signatures
so think about this this scenario
right we don't know what happened with
my wife's absentee ballot despite the
fact that we follow the exact
instructions on following up as to
whether the absentee ballot was counted
every single person that i've checked on
not just these two these are the ones
i'm showing because i can 100
confirm it has no status update on their
absentee ballot
and i have no idea as to whether i voted
or not but i know that the ballot
according to the law was sent to my
previous address
and they aren't checking for signatures
and ballots are being rejected at a rate
of 30 times
lower than in previous elections wow
someone doesn't even need to forge my
signature it requires
le it requires less mustache twisting
than forging a sick note in high school
somebody just go oh yeah you know and i
don't know i don't know i fill it in joe
biden
yeah got him and by the way i don't know
if you guys remember but uh you moved
years ago yeah a little while it's not
like it's not like it's a six month lag
no it's not like it's a six month long
by the way speaking with cnn before we
get to the lawsuit they're saying seven
state certified results is trump makes
baseless
fraud claims i always say what happened
to the word alleged
nah you're gonna be like baseless norah
alleged fraud claims
that by the way we actually do have some
injunctions that have been filed we
actually do
have some seizing of property that has
been going forward so
if you are following this in the media
right now they want you to believe that
donald trump wants to throw out millions
of votes
just to try and win to disenfranchise
voters and that is
dangerous because if we actually follow
the constitutional
both letter of the law and spirit of the
law to have a free
and fair election guess what you're
going to have violence and riding in the
streets because people have been told
that donald trump is stealing it from
them what about my vote what about my
wife's vote
i'm not going to burn down a walgreens
but if it turns out that their votes
weren't counted and my non-vote was i'm
going to be pissed
i might pick it a walgreens even though
it's not their fault but i don't know
i'm just angry it's the language of the
unheard
you know it might be walgreen's fault
i'm not sure it might be vloggers yeah
what if your ballot is at walgreens
you know what same day testing you know
what people are saying they use this
word disenfranchised disenfranchised but
you can only disenfranchise someone who
cast a legal vote exactly right it's
like saying
we've disenfranchised all of the voters
in singapore from casting their ballot
in the american election yeah and you're
like well
well yes yeah we did not let them vote
but the point was they were never
franchised to begin with we
disenfranchised the crypts in not
letting them take old men's gran torinos
at will
dane i mean they weren't what a sad
state of affairs in this country where
latin kings can't earn themselves a
tear-drop
tattoo this is unbelievable
and it's happened to me so by the way
everyone watching right now please hit
like
this second right now hit like because
we want to see
if this actually gets out to people and
gets through the youtube algorithm just
watching right now
hit like that's all you have to do and i
do ask that you follow up on your own
ballots okay
let's move on to michigan there's a
lawsuit right that's been filed by
sydney powell can we just say the kraken
has been released
can we just because we were talking
about does she have some bombshells uh i
would say that this
certainly would suffice doesn't mean
that it's going to
win but certainly pretty thorough and
certainly something
that absolutely that in in in the
cumulative case that's being made i
don't see how you throw this out oh
there's no doubt i mean look
even just over the course of the last
couple of days you had the city of
detroit
have their own council move to intervene
in the michigan suit
in order to defend the election itself
in the process now that makes sense
because wayne county is the center
of what are where a lot of the
controversy was which we covered
that too yeah i mean you know i don't
want to insult hell it's not even one of
the circles
so so when you look at when you look at
the all the allegations that are brought
you really do see
a lot of support for where those
arguments were made and what you're
seeing as well is
putting a lie to all of the coverage
about oh wait a minute
they're talking about hugo chavez and
hugo chavez died years ago and it's like
guys
no one's saying that hugo chavez came
from beyond the grave to switch ballots
in wayne county but
what they're saying is follow the trail
of where these systems are and the
questions that are raised and that's
only one of multiple
it's a silly argument che guevara died
years ago that doesn't stop [ __ ]
from putting on a t-shirt
absolutely rage against the machine
let's wear a t-shirt of the guy who
banned
jazz go ahead
no i i agree 100 with what you're saying
i think what we still need though is a
win we need a very
clear win and i think a judge taking
this and saying hey
there's enough to go forward like
happened in pennsylvania was a very
clear win the only problem was the
supreme court of pennsylvania was like
well this says we did something wrong
and i don't think we did anything wrong
so bye-bye with the lawsuit right so i
hope that doesn't happen in georgia or
michigan
with anything that we've got going on
eventually it goes to the charleston
spare me the snark today
how about snip i want some stuff
so in michigan both the michigan the
georgia lawsuits there are some uh
there are some allegations that are sort
of joint right they apply to both states
um one of course is that the dominion
software was accessed by agents from
china and iran in order to manipulate
elections including the 2020 election so
this is the big one the dominion
software issue
this is something that they do have uh
apparently whistleblowers
uh and they do have sworn testimony from
people who are cyber security experts
and there are some independent analyses
that you can look up
right now now let's be clear i want to
be clear about something affidavits
are considered admissible correct most
of the time right value at the
statements but yes yes you have to
evaluate the statements
statistical evidence is admissible by an
expert correct by an expert correct
now in tandem when you have affidavits
from people saying hold on a second we
were sent away
because they said that a pipe burst and
turns out that it didn't then there were
all these vote dumps that don't make
sense then you have an
expert analysis say hold on there are
these vote dumps that actually
have never occurred anywhere in nature
in a normal election in
tandem that is serious evidence we don't
just have affidavits yeah we don't just
have circumstantial evidence they're
affidavits which can be corroborated by
statistical anomalies
as well as potentially videographic
evidence
so this is pretty big so let's go here
there are 289 thousand more ballots that
were processed this is in the uh the
michigan uh brief that you can read
in four precincts or townships over what
the capacity allows
they're producing spikes that indicate
manual adjustment is what it says by
those operating the system or buying
attack from outside actors and by the
way what's interesting about this if you
look it up in michigan we have all these
sources available at lateralcutter.com
you have the more conservative the
county the more abnormal the spikes in
some cases yeah
or the precinct at least like you look
at kent county now you have liberals in
grand rapids i'm from michigan so i know
the state pretty well but there's some
precincts in kent county that are
unbelievably
conservative yeah and all of a sudden
with these dumps they
they switch um and what this means is
they have a certain capacity where you
go how many ballots can you process
right how many ballots can you count in
this time right right they've estimated
that number
and there's 289 000 more ballots that
all experts said could be processed in
that time
right exactly this is also the state
that couldn't get their count done in a
week
and they're like well maybe we just
sprinted too hard in that one hour where
he counted 250 300 000 more votes
we had to take a break after that or
something this is one of those things
where if there is an explanation
it's readily apparent if there is an
explanation other than a manual switch
of votes if you reach the capacity of a
certain system or a certain ability to
do things
and you're well past that we're not
talking about oh you managed to squeeze
in a couple because your thumbs are
working real fast right
i mean when you get that many more you
have to be able to answer the question
and all we hear
is crickets i can just tell you today we
were over capacity that's why we didn't
have those clips ready
too many because we do not know we do
not have the budget of cnn only they
don't use it they tell you nothing
so you can clearly see like we have the
ability to process this much before the
show
we screwed up you trusted us but we
fixed it
by the way hit the notification bell if
you're subscribed because uh
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
not all
you know we're every weekday morning 20
through thursday at 10am eastern
here's another one an independent
analysis found uh trump's margin of
defeat in four states occurred within
just
four data dumps this is a quote from it
vote pattern analysis
a few key vote updates and competitive
states were unusually large in size and
had an unusually high biden to trump
ratio
we demonstrate from expected result we
demonstrate so the results differ enough
from expected results to be caused for
concern
here's an example in michigan so in
michigan you have um i don't know if
it's 143
179 000 uh votes that occurred really
from just a few data dumps
yeah now this happened keep in mind most
of these dumps
in the dead of night remember when we
all went home yeah right when people say
why
no we were here we were one of the few
networks we were here while that
happened the only reason we stopped the
stream was because
they said we're not going to count
anymore yeah we're going to start at 9
and we said well i guess there's nothing
left for us to cover they're gonna start
at nine i took an hour and a half nap in
a hammock and said
now trump's losing and here's the thing
that's important to note it's not a lot
of people are throwing around like
there's this there's this debunked graph
right i'm not an analysis i'm not a
statistician okay i want to be very
clear about that
but there are people who've done a lot
of work and there have also been frauds
they're i think uh
not necessarily a fraud but got it wrong
that dr shiva guy yeah created a graph
that wasn't quite accurate you don't
need to share
i wouldn't share that again we have some
uh
some analysts and we'll have their links
up at louderwithcredit.com here's
something that's important
if you look at the ratio right when you
uh take a sample
the larger the sample okay there's an
inverse relationship between the ratio
the margin that would occur between two
votes for example if you were to take
uh a poll right let's just say a
precinct we're just here in the lottery
credit precinct you might have 100 for
donald trump maybe someone out there
voted for libertarian hope you enjoy the
downfall of western civilization but you
feel good with your black tar heroine
but i'm pretty sure it'd be like 98 for
donald trump yeah
then you go to the block of where we are
here and then okay maybe now you have a
few hundred people maybe you get a 90
10.
right now you go to a few thousand
people because you have a generally
closer sampling to that of society at
large you end up with
an 80 20. if you get into the many
thousands hundreds of thousands
that's where you get something more
representative of the american public
could be 50 50 could be 60 40 it would
be considered a blowout in almost any
precinct
at a 70 30 including san francisco okay
just to be clear but in these huge data
dumps with hundreds of thousands of
votes in places like michigan
you have some mark percentages wise for
people understand like
96 4 for biden so we have the opposite
what we're seeing here is the larger the
data dumps that occur the more people
the greater the margin the greater the
ratio of joe biden to donald trump
which does not occur anywhere else in
nature
that is a statistical anomaly which by
the way has only happened
in these major swing states namely a
handful of major cities detroit
philadelphia atlanta and i can't i think
milwaukee yeah exactly this is one of
the most interesting analysis is the
analyses that i've seen uh vote pattern
analysis we're way past
getting pronunciation right today
exactly go and read this all right i
read the entire thing
one point i wanted to make is that these
all of these happen
yeah it's it's a new thing it's
surprising um all of these data dumps
happened within five hours of each other
they happened
only in the specific places that needed
to have this happen for the swing
state vote to change and if they did an
analysis and said look we have we're not
getting
places workers we're not exactly
everybody was gone right
we have no bias here all we're saying is
if we look at all of the data 6 000
vote dumps and you normalize the data to
make sure you're comparing apples to
apples
they said this never happens and if it
does one thing happens
three things happened in this one
instance especially in michigan and they
said
look if you just put these in line with
99
of the other data dumps that's all you
have to do take them from the 99.7 to 99
donald trump wins each of those yeah he
also won the bellwether county so there
are a lot there are a lot of things that
would have to happen for the first time
here in this election that have never
happened before and by the way
didn't happen in other counties and
those things just so happened
to take place in the counties or in the
precincts we have hundreds of affidavits
of people saying by the way they sent us
away uh from poll watching
and we weren't allowed to see and they
boarded up with bristol boards and they
had ballots coming in coolers
doesn't matter what cnn says that the
red wagon was just bringing in camera
equipment which by the way
is such horseshit yeah listen we carry
camera equipment
you cannot protect a multi thousand
dollar lens
it's not safe not in a red wagon you
don't want it right
when that came out i was like what about
the coolers i was like okay okay great
you know you
had this camera equipment and that's all
that was you were bringing it in
okay why in the did you need the bristol
boards then
if you're putting cameras inside of the
room why are you blocking the windows
why are you sending people away right
the whole thing is open it's fine okay
great then just be consistent the act
when that came out the first thing i
thought was
why were you hiding that's very good i'm
gonna let you finish but first i gotta
process these hundred and forty three
thousand votes look at that ninety six
four bites
by the way that is enough that is enough
i'm sorry i have to go
that is enough by itself she could have
filed a one-page document in michigan
and said
this doesn't happen in life we have to
dig here and that would have been enough
and there's more than
in in georgia the state flips if you
just throw up people who uh kind of like
have
registration in two different states
yeah or double votes the right it's a 12
000 vote margin keep in mind some people
still think it's like 16 18 000 or even
14 000 no
because even in counting without
checking signatures the machine
ballots twice yeah they found 5 500
votes most of which for donald trump
i don't know how that happens if not
that what warrants an actual
audit if not that we were told before
this
uh well there's no elect there's no
election fraud it's never happened to
well it happens but like very small
numbers it's not widespread
it might be a couple hundred then they
found 5500 ballots and they go oh it's
not enough to flip the state yeah but
you were wrong about all the other [ __ ]
and i think you're lying about the
current
[ __ ] yeah i do appreciate that there is
at least some level of intellectual
honesty going on with
leftist media because they're they're
out there they used to say there's no
such thing as voter fraud
then they stepped back and they were
like well there's no
widespread widespread there's no
substantial widespread but here's the
thing it doesn't have to be
no widespread and substantial you don't
have to you know commit voter fraud in
california
and oregon and montana and utah and
massachusetts
you only have to find a couple of
districts you only have to do
things and a couple of precincts now
that's not the way you do it if you're
really going to do a good job of hiding
it
right because this is the statistical
analysis now here's one thing i think
will be interesting as we move forward
people are going
what's the next step you get in when you
get into this evidence you start going
okay let's compare a 964 in these
jurisdictions
right dumps to even the most liberal
democrat
biden-friendly jurisdictions that use
the same software right and if you don't
see those same dumps no or let's even
compare them to the liberal
most pro-biden uh uh demographic sorry
counties that you could imagine
mail-in ballots but by hand let's see if
you find a 96-4
let's see if you find a 92-8 consistent
you know what you find in san francisco
which i think is used as the example of
the
most it's it's 90 10. it's it's 90 10.
they have not been able to get
up past like you know yeah killer t
cells
uh also we're gonna move on to georgia
here uh but first
la mayor eric garcetti there's a name uh
he uh
he bent the need of black lives matter
remember he voted to cut the lapd by a
hundred yeah
yeah well now here he is having the lapd
guard his home from black lives matter
protesters who apparently didn't get the
memo that he's one of you
um they're protesting because they don't
want biden to appoint him
to the cabinet here you go
[Music]
thank god he has the military there
otherwise he might require a
gun sorry the rest of you californians
with eight rounds nine rounds is that
what it is a ten round magazine a bullet
button
galley you know it it is
the irony of of the blm protesters
i just want to explode sorry i lost my
train of thought
you're gonna bring it back no no no no
no no the brain exploded it did
it did well first of all i loved that
certain kiss eddie yeah i mean look at
him it was based on hanging with mr
cooper
yeah it was nice
don't call it formulaic for a comeback
oh
oh jeez please don't tell me he's dead
because some people say it's important
no i don't think all right let's go on
to georgia because it's a hundred
four-page lawsuit
oh my gosh that would be like more
poverty mr cooper come on
what did i say what did i say what was
he talking did he say something where's
your rick to kind of protect
me earlier
i said that it's just what i say is what
i say
but did you say something nah it's
confusing it's confusing
and that's why you hang with me so
you're in the loop
this sitcom did not last no no i blame
patrick duffy and step by step that's
some [ __ ]
patrick duffy brillo head yeah it was a
hit
you think that's what rand paul got the
haircut so let's go to georgia theory
um sydney powell the lawsuit there many
affidavits again
uh as well as statistical evidence and
some video footage uh it's summarizing
and we have this at light with
credit.com a few things let me kind of
hit them
votes were switched in biden's favor
during the recount these are the claims
in the uh
in the suit right uh there was a lack of
procedures that were being followed
during the election
um and georgia purchased dominion voting
systems despite knowing vulnerabilities
which by the way
democrats warned about that and texas
rejected using dominion voting systems
the pipe burst story remember we there
we were there election night
we were covering it because some systems
just went down in georgia which we don't
know the systems that went down if they
were dominion i don't think we know that
yet but no we covered that election
night you can go back if you want to
watch the nine hour stream
people gonna know where you there are
receipts it's called a nine-hour stream
right do your own research
remember the systems went down yeah and
we've talked about how long
in counties and then the pipe burst and
we're like well i guess they stopped
counting that happened that night i
remember talking about it
turns out that didn't happen and there
may be video footage of them
still counting so what they did is they
told people the pipe burst you have to
go home and from 10
p.m to 1 a.m they continued counting
votes without poll watchers if i'm a
judge i go oh okay well let's just grab
those votes and re
we can't know which ones from that time
well let's take an estimate throw them
out
throw them out you have to why do you
want to disenfranchise you sent people
home with a [ __ ] story about a pipe
bursting and we have video proof that
you lied yeah throw them out throw them
out throw them out
the super speed counting with less
people is pretty amazing
it is amazing they're very efficient
when no one is watching you know that's
all it is
sometimes i just gotta go to a quiet
spot you know i fake it pipe burst and i
just i can bang out a brief real fast
hold on i can't talk i'm vote laundering
the quiet morning so this is actually
right here in the actual lawsuit this to
me is really big because it says
specifically video from the state farm
arena in fulton county shows that on
november 3rd after the polls closed
election workers falsely claimed the
water leak
required the facility to close all poll
workers and challengers were evacuated
for several hours
about 10 pm however several election
workers remained unsupervised and
unchallenged working at the computers
for the voting tabulation machines until
after
1 a.m and of course they failed
dominion that name keeps popping up it's
the eddie haskell of voting systems
it can't tabulate we can't tabulate
which votes took place during that
oh no now again this is what happened
the media has not acknowledged this the
media oh a pipe burst and
this is what would happen if you're
watching cnn or fox news and we'll talk
about tucker carlson in a little bit
i don't dislike the guy but i think it's
something that warren's being addressed
considering sydney powell shenanigans
and i believe that the kraken is
it's a kraken so
they just said a pipe burst on election
night we told you a pipe burst on
election night right then afterward they
said
by the way there's no evidence right
they said completely unfounded uh
unfounded claims of voter fraud there's
no evidence of voter fraud or
irregularities but we followed up hold
on a second
that pipe didn't burst you know that we
followed up on that now we say wait a
second
there is videographic evidence and it's
filed in this suit under penalty of
perjury that they have videographic
evidence of those people sending folks
away and still counting votes
for three hours you don't see that on
the media right now so you still think
all of this is unfounded and that
coincides with the avid davidson people
saying we were sent home because of pipe
burst and we didn't go back and then all
of a sudden these votes were in there
again this is not just he said she said
it's
he said video and a few ten thousand
extra votes beyond capacity
what do you want to bet that it's the
same people who maintain the epstein
cameras
are like yeah the area where the pipe
burst that camera was down
strange cameras at all they never work
i would can we just get a ring doorbell
and assign an intern to charge it
they store them in coolers ah that's why
where's the camera
hey quick someone get my coleman every
security camera is like 180p
yeah exactly like you can't literally
there's only one pixel there yeah that's
the entire screen you're just showing me
video footage from the the hunt for red
october where
that's not the pipe in the arena this is
just the great dictator with charlie
chaplin but are you not entertained
it was good it was pretty good i mean
this is one of those questions that
keeps being asked which is where's the
data of the logs
as the data is coming in how are we
going to be able to audit how are we
going to look at it
all you all you'll be able to do is look
at the answer you'd be able to see oh
during that period
it actually had a huge drop in the
number of tables yes there were people
in there
yes they were counting we just didn't
want to get too far behind and so there
was like a 99
drop and this is how many few we're
going through instead somehow
at the end of the period you go black
box magic all of these ballots were kind
of let me ask you this
there's a legal process for votes right
there's a chain of custody
uh the legal process for votes does it
involve having accountability and poll
watchers who are able to verify the
votes yes
yes okay now if those people are sent
home uh
should you continue counting votes
depends in the jurisdiction but most of
the time no
what if they're sent home on a lie that
a pipe burst in the videographic
evidence shows that that is not the case
does that seem like a problem bill you
know
it does now that doesn't prove
everything else no of course
but to me that's enough to throw the
certification of georgia in doubt not to
mention
you have anywhere the estimates are
between six and eleven thousand votes
from people who are out of state i'm
suffering from the same condition doc
i just showed you my registration in two
different states that was accidental
let alone if someone wanted to do it on
purpose yeah it would have been very
easy for me to vote twice i guarantee
you i could have voted twice actually
well and if there's a logical
explanation i still don't know that i
haven't
they should have already come out with
it someone may have right
in the system i still have no idea where
my vote or my wife or nana's is
yeah but the guy with the mask told me i
could track it right
that was like the full like the most
full mask i've seen like it was like all
the way up to his eyeballs and then down
to his adam's house that's a guy
giving by himself but just like he does
everywhere
geez what's the matter with that stephen
so this is another one
uh more again statistical evidence
looking at the anomaly so now we have
okay affidavits people saying we were
turned away
people saying all right you know what
they continued counting votes and them
saying no no there's no evidence now we
have that evidence that they did
continue accounting votes with no poll
watchers no accountability and they lied
about a pipe bursting
and then we combine that with some crazy
statistical anomalies that have happened
in georgia here we have matt brainer to
the voter integrity project
uh talking about it let's roll the clip
all the analysis that we've done don't
really require you to say trust me about
a magical mathematical formula or some
pattern we discovered or
something that supposedly happened in
the software of the voting machines
i can give you the list of the people
who vote in this election
who filed national change of address
cards in georgia moving themselves to
another state
and i can also show you the subsequent
state voter registrations
of these individuals in other states who
then cast
earlier absentee ballots back in georgia
i can show you the names of the people
and the records of them
having voted in multiple states in the
raw data the states make available
so this isn't speculative yeah and by
the way the fbi has requested the data
so that they can review it which means
you know it'll disappear
absolutely when did the guy from hitman
get into voter products yeah
and the career is pivotal in front of an
exact
tone of his flesh color yeah exactly my
eyes kept focusing
i mean maybe it's their squinty but you
know the whole time
i want to really pop because this is you
know a big this is a big deal for me
how do you feel about taupe it's a good
background no i don't really think that
i'm thinking something uh maybe not how
about sable
a good sand no earth tones so
light brown you're fired
uh by the way this is something the
lawsuit also uh calls for an emergency
declaratory judgment
that voting machines be seized and
impounded immediately for a forensic
audit and to be clear federal judge uh
timothy batten i want to make sure i get
his name right to the bat and senior
reapproved a temporary restraining order
late last night declaring that election
officials were barred from wiping or
altering dominion voting machines using
you know hillary's like server you got
to do it nothing wrong here
consider wiping it at this point it's
ridiculous
that was on the table
it's getting so just so some folks
everyone needs to go read this but this
order came out last night at
i believe 10 eastern there was a revised
order that came out that said
no you cannot go and delete these
devices right now here's one of the
things that's interesting before you
file these kinds of motions in almost
every jurisdiction you have to confer
ahead of time because courts want to
know like is there really a fight here
or not
so that means that most likely sidney
powell and her legal team
said hey we want you to not wipe these
devices tomorrow and they were like
meh you got to go back and tell us not
to right so the allegation here was that
these were going to be deleted
today today that these devices would be
wiped by the end of the day
on november 30th while all of these
questions were out there now that
now obviously that's why all of this
rushed to put all this evidence together
to get it out there
get it on file by wednesday so that
there could even be the fact that there
was like appearing on sunday
sure that which seemed like a formatting
thing by the way to me if you look at
the way the words were spaced
i mean some odd symbols i don't think it
was typos there's the you know being
able to check on and all caps
the spell check doesn't work that well
and then anyone she's really negative
knows that i mean look
it's frustrating stuff but you look at
all the subsequent briefing doesn't have
those issues and we will those will be
they're distractions but they don't
touch the merits and if someone is only
pointing out
the typos or the formatting errors it's
because they can't attack the merits
yeah before you get to the rampant
possible voter fraud there's already
enough in georgia to just flip the
margins
yeah voting out of state as far as
double but there's already enough to
completely evaporate
yeah joe biden's lead just to be clear
about that georgia absolute if you're
just counting legal votes and you're not
even getting into statistical anomalies
it should flip yeah exactly and if
they're like oh here's our excuse and
we're just like
oh we can't count nope nope i have no
idea which vote it turns out we
counted all the votes in safari private
mode no no
we can't do that no here are pictures of
bel delphine the remedy for that is that
legally
they cannot by federal law they cannot
send electors
if there is fraud if they suspect that
there is fraud they have the ability
because the federal law does say that
you have to be able to make sure like if
there is a suspicion of fraud
right you can't send electors to us or
i'm sorry not that you can't but you
have the ability to not send electors
and say hey we can't certify our vote
we can't tell you who won because you
guys cheated and then you shuffled the
papers around so we couldn't figure it
out
so now right you don't get those
electoral votes they just disappear from
the map
and so this is what this is where the
timing of the process really matters
and it mattered in 2000 mm-hmm
and now it matters again i'm following
youtube because you can certify it keeps
magical
descendants to the electoral college and
what they're saying now
is undo the certifications yeah because
of the fraud
don't send it to the electoral college
because we need to look at it and is
that
unprecedented no no that's true al gore
had 37 days wanting to count only three
counties yeah and he and george bush
lost every single case until it got to
the supreme court court where they said
like why are you only account recount
three guys let's recap the whole state
he said no no no no no no
they said no we're gonna recount
everything he said no they said
dismissed effectively
that's not true can you imagine if in
2000 al gore came up and was like look
guys
before the count's over we're just gonna
destroy all of the chats
hanging or otherwise right um and in
fact we're just gonna annihilate all of
the records
i invented but i want except for three
counties and i don't wanna see any of
those
cubano votes somewhere venezuelans what
do they know
socialism works if it's done right so
does my masseuse
here's what i will say because january
6th this is going to go before the floor
right when they confirm the election i
think january september 6
any republican at this point any
republican who does not is they will all
have their time to issue objections
who does not issue an objection to this
election
i will say primary them vote them out
yeah i'm not saying that you can say all
of these vote you can prove every single
claim here but anyone who has no problem
with these elections
these anomalies these irregularities and
selection any republican up there so
people talk about team trump people talk
about republicans in the swamp listen
if you care about the future of our
constitutional republic you better have
an objection
january 6th anyone who doesn't you make
my [ __ ] list
right i just want to be really clear and
let me let me be let me be clear about
something else too i said this before
joe biden if he wins i'll accept him as
the president if we go through the
process
it is very clear right now unless this
goes to the supreme court there will be
no honest tally no investigation of
these votes and to save time
i will say president biden for the next
four years if that's the way it goes
but i will i will stake my i'll claim
this grand rapid no i'm not going to
consider him my president
yeah count me on that crowd a t-shirt
not my president
if there are no objections and none of
these things are examined if we don't
throw out at least the votes from people
who are out of state
and dead folks and people who are
underage i know you have a lot of milk
toast commentators out there saying well
those are no
no nope cheated sorry i if you play
rummy cube with me
and you cheat i don't go oh well that's
one for you no no no no it's not
if i cheat sometimes i win if you cheat
sometimes you and that's not how this
works
i'm sorry i am not one of those guys i
will be unconvinced
yeah and the power actually so you made
a good point primary those people out
actually in the states the state
legislatures are the ones that have the
power so
if you're in wisconsin and michigan and
pennsylvania and georgia right now and
your state legislature
does not step forward and say hey if
you're not willing to do an audit and
investigate these claims we will not
certify this vote and send anybody to
the election we'll just keep everybody
home
that would keep it from being 270.
nobody would be able to imagine
georgia they're talking about people who
are out of state the situation that we
just showed you
in michigan where i am registered to
vote yeah and i
did not vote in michigan and there's a
ballot sent in michigan let's just
assume this kind of same scenario where
there was an excuse in michigan which is
not outside the realm of possibility
in georgia it was a pipe in michigan it
was they didn't even come up with a lie
because it was wayne county they just
thought let's put up some
bristol boards bringing some wagons in
the back door uncle sam's none the wiser
so imagine if in michigan where i'm
registered to vote
and my wife's vote doesn't count so from
what we've seen her vote hasn't counted
thus far could be 99
chance and i'm just wrong about this and
it's like using the old my grandma with
the vcr
but my grandma's vote didn't go through
my wife's didn't vote didn't go through
despite a formal of address
i'm registered to vote and there is a 99
chance that someone received my ballot
there because ballots are mailed out to
anyone who's registered to vote
and that just takes place when they
bristol board up the precinct tell all
the poll watchers to go home and can
fill in anything they want in the ballot
why wouldn't my ballot be in there and
why wouldn't they toss my wife's
and my grandmas that's the point here do
you have any idea how
rampant this can be just we we've done
this in reverse
we've gone through the statistical
analysis and then i said you know what
on a hunch anecdotally let me see if
there's some
some screwery going on with my vote and
i said there is
let me check and i went down every
single family member in michigan
and none of them added up yeah bill
isn't that a legal argument where once
you've once you've kind of crossed the
line
isn't that like like fruit of the
poisonous tree i've heard that term be
thrown around a lot like once you've
crossed the line and broken the law
don't you have to
broke you broke the law there and so we
can't trust what you've said after this
in that same voting process
like is there is there an argument to be
made there um
you're mixing legal metaphors but or
metaphors i'll be honest i don't know
or maladies uh no the point is about
rotten fruit
fruit of the place joshua
if you were to go and collect evidence
of violation of the fourth amendment
through the poisonous trees any evidence
that you would have obtained in a legal
search and seizure what you're talking
about is a weighing of the credibility
of certain evidence
which is to say if you've done this
certain thing wrong it can be used as
evidence
in some circumstances to show you
continue to do wrong the other principle
i think you're talking about
is if we cannot establish the legality
that the processes were completed
for example when alito said hey back in
the election he goes hold these ballots
aside
we have to analyze these ballots that
may have come in late
he's saying as a group we might have to
consider these and
these votes as not legally cast votes
right and that means you could take an
entire you can say the process was done
incorrectly
and as a result there's legal grounds to
say this entire batch of balance is out
so what we're saying here is that if the
earlier points in the chain
were all broken they lead to a place
where the election procedures were not
followed
then there can be a scenario where large
large batches of ballots coolers
whatever you're carrying them in
are all thrown out and here's the thing
here's the thing you do trick-or-treat
pillowcase
yeah look good enough it's just the
leader of the free world you don't have
to believe
you know the show you don't have to
believe random people you don't have to
believe your elected officials would say
wait a minute
we should just do a real audit here we
should just really look at it you can
look at the federal judges in two
different states who are currently
taking action
in junctive action who were saying
please stop destroying the evidence
let us just look at it file your briefs
and we'll go from there so this week in
georgia we're democrats
with a hammer going huh what what i'm
sorry hold on a second i'll be right
back i just gotta take care of this hard
drive
uh where's the magnetron like santa's
fraudulent elves
in detroit it wasn't poisonous she was a
poison dart frog they just ah
blow-darted people poisoned dart frog
darts really and then they came up 143
000 votes well that's one way
it's a part of our legal system it was a
safeguard that the founding fathers put
in
murder but not at all not if you get
their vote
it's not murder it's a surprise nap
you know the best gifts are the ones
that are unexpected that's true yeah
and the ones that you make yourself just
rubbing it on a frog
like apocalypto certified
okay so let's go on okay i think we've
any other comments on this no good okay
let's move on to uh
to uh tucker carlson here um okay all
right this is uh this is uh it's getting
intense and we're gonna take your chat
as to where you line up
uh and hit like by the way if you're
watching right now like boom click
like the like button we're just gonna be
doing this for a couple days just click
like we want to see
this information through the youtube
algorithms despite us not being an
authoritative source
namely that we actually provide sources
so um tucker carlson a lot of people
have been giving him some
some crap and a lot of people are saying
okay he's not a conservative he's not
amongst us let me let me
full disclosure here with tucker carlson
and this is the case with many people at
fox news or in media i have had some
personal interactions with them so i
want to be clear and so i
i try and avoid talking about these uh
subjects because of the inside baseball
and i know that i may be biased
multiple personal interactions and you
guys have probably you can even search i
know there were some on
air they've been mixed now yeah that
being said i want to make sure that i'm
uh going through the claims in tucker
carlson's history on the merits and i
don't believe andrew breitbart
believed in ronald reagan's um you know
the 11th commandment you don't attack
your fellow conservative
right and i certainly don't believe in
in just attacking people because they
disagree with you
slightly on an issue that is different
from fundamentally changing your world
view
or throwing someone else under the bus
who is also conservative and also on
board with our
cause uh because you may be throwing a
temper tantrum
now i don't think that tucker carlson
always does this i think that tucker
carlson has done
a lot of good work i agree with tucker
carlson's views in a lot of ways
but anytime you have someone who has
espoused views that change seemingly
with
whichever platform is afforded to him at
that time like
we have bow tie version tucker carlson
at cnn crossfire
uh then we have msnbc tucker carlson and
then we have fox news tucker calls and
we have post donald trump tucker carlson
okay this is where you get into it and
let's start off with this sydney powell
tucker carlson caught a lot of flack
because
he criticized sydney powell's lawsuits
publicly
and also called her work ethic or i
guess he should say her legal ethic into
question before the suits
were even filed this is what pissed a
lot of people off
we simply wanted to see the details how
could you not want to see them
so we invited sidney powell on the show
we would have given her the whole hour
we would have given her the entire week
actually and listened quietly the whole
time at rapt attention
that's a big story but she never showed
us
any evidence despite a lot of requests
polite requests
uh first off sydney paul said that they
were not play requests now again i will
say inside baseball we've invited sidney
powell on this show and at that point in
time they were very clear well there are
some things that we can't discuss
because of legality until we file these
and we have to be careful
this was happening behind the scenes
here he didn't see us go [ __ ]
right but i really wanted but i really
want this in the light please
politely officially listen to me like
listen listen we'll see if we can get
sidney powell on but if she can't i
understand because the legal issues
maybe we can get her on afterwards
why would i want to undercut her other
than to
highlight the fact that they didn't give
us an exclusive scoop we would have
given her an entire hour oh
really and that could be admissible and
then she loses i'm sorry that was
completely off-base
it was a shitty thing to do and it's not
something that i would imagine a
conservative who wants to win this
election
would do yeah as if that's like a really
nice thing he's doing for
her like we would have given her a whole
hour or a week oh that's so good of you
we asked for her debate prep beforehand
so that we could air it yeah in front of
her opponents
and she politely declined and so what a
[ __ ]
and i super wanted it and i super wanted
please
so that's the situation that happened
there and i say behind the scenes
this happens all the time and you try to
you have to try and work with these
people especially when this could be one
of the biggest
lawsuits in american history certainly
as it relates to uh election fraud
ever and now we see the evidence that
has been provided cumulatively
and if there is not an apology issued
that's an issue doesn't mean that tucker
carlson's voice should be discounted and
it doesn't mean that everyone should
tune him out just because he don't like
that he did that but i do think it was a
crappy thing to do
here's something too that you need to
know about tucker carlson tutor carlson
you see this a lot with people on air
they present themselves as the everyman
you know you had bill o'reilly doing
this like just looking out for the folks
yeah
you haven't met a folk in 30 years okay
still you have someone go out and talk
to the folks for you
sometimes he walks on their backs oh
yeah sometimes he has them walk on his
back oh whoops
tell the folks to bring me some food
so um tucker tucker carlson was raised
uh he
is kind of the definition when people
talk about a wealthy elitist okay uh his
dad married into the swanson
fortune right this is where he is the
swanson fortune this is a guy who's been
that does not discount anybody's views
but for me it's if you go hey i'm now
championing the working class because i
understand
it and that's kind of your your brand i
think you need to be transparent about
the fact that uh that's not
really um something that you would
really have a whole lot in common with i
think donald trump does that very well
donald trump seems to care about the
little guy in the united states
and he's very clear that um he's not one
of the guys as seen by his penthouse
apartment
entirely played it in goal
the only man with more gold is ben
carson i could not believe when i saw
his bathroom in florida what up
so let's look at tucker carlson's views
again the reason people have a problem
as far as consistency
um he was a pro pro iraq war republican
for a while
uh before he became sort of what is seen
as a quintessential sort of think tank
libertarian right this means the people
who work at cato
people maybe work at some kind of
liberty institute for freedom prosperity
insert here foundation
fund that's my favorite um and uh he
tried to ingratiate himself to the sort
of intellectual
conservative um friedman type think tank
base now when tucker crosston was
asked in 2003 about the iraq war he gave
a long list of reasons to invade and
then he ended with
uh i mean what other evidence do we need
and to be fair tucker carlson has been
very clear about the fact that his views
have changed i'm not saying that
people's views cannot change
but they have changed dramatically he
has made a 180 and he's done it several
times
from cnn to msnbc to fox news to
post-trump fox news and i can say this
because i was on fox news pre-trump with
tucker carlson and it's not the same guy
who you're seeing right now
so consistency in this case does matter
when you're looking at something that
seems like it could actually irreparably
harm
this investigation from sydney powell
which it could
yeah i think it's possible and look i
don't know that i took it quite the same
way that you did when he came out with
that my my initial thought was that that
doesn't seem like the right thing to say
you shouldn't be saying that but he
needed
at the time everybody was talking about
this story and everybody was discarding
this story and saying there's no
evidence she's just holding press
conferences it's another thing that's
going out so i think he was fine to
cover it and say hey we've reached out
we've tried to do this
we'll present evidence once it happens i
think where he crossed the line with
what you were saying is that
he seemed to make a point of the fact
that she would not come on the show
yeah and he seemed to kind of throw a
little bit of a temper tantrum about
that but then he said that he was rude
right and then he kind of cloaked it in
we will we hope that evidence comes out
and i think that's true if he ends up
just having a misstep there
fine but you're i think what you're
saying is there's other evidence that
says that probably a lot of missteps and
you know i'll give you a little inside
baseball with my experience at fox news
i'm certainly not saying that uh that
fox news tells people what they can and
can't say
but sometimes they tell people what they
can and can't say allegedly
a while ago as a self-described and it's
interesting because he looks
older because the bow tie was his
gimmick for a while uh self-described
libertarian here he is i am a
right-winger
sort of a libertarian uh right winger
but i'm far out
and i make no secret of it radical man
here he is bashing those so-called
libertarians recently
our leadership class remains resolutely
libertarian
committed to the rhetoric of markets
when it serves them
utterly libertine on questions of
culture
okay so this is the issue again these
views change depending on where he is
like cnn msnbc where he didn't have
really great ratings and he's been very
open about that
i was having worked at fox news um there
certainly is they don't tell you exactly
what to say but they do tell you which
third rails to avoid this is true of any
network
i ran into this quite a bit he stepped
on a few
as you see with what happened just look
at what happened in the election with uh
mitt romney at that point rick santorum
was basically persona non greta when it
came down to both of them they had
chosen
mitt romney was basically a coronation
at fox news and i will tell you that
behind the scenes
it was well known that you were not
welcome if you uh issued the criticisms
of mitt romney that i think were very
valid
namely that we know now he's a wiener
um and fox news whenever you're with a
network it frames what you are allowed
uh i don't want to say they don't come
down and say hey tucker tell them you're
libertarian today then they go hey tell
them you're populist and hate
hate libertarians today what does happen
is they say hey this is what's working
with ratings
this is what people are receptive to and
this is what's required for a
multi-billion dollar corporation to
continue succeeding if you want that
nice slot
he doesn't own any of his shows a lot of
people at fox news don't even own the
rights to their own name you need to be
clear about that so
these people i'm not saying they're
mouthpieces for someone else or for a
network but
when you look at a track record over
time and you go the views did change
based on where the check was coming from
that does give one pause especially when
combined with the fact that
i don't know how any conservative goes
out and attacks sydney powell before the
suit is filed i don't understand it yeah
when you combine that with
remarkable inconsistency i can see why
some people might be upset um
here's another one by the way uh some
more information for people out there uh
it was only after taking over the kelly
slot at fox news
that he really did start going all in on
trump because i remember when i used to
appear on on fox news
um and this was back i think trump ran
in the primary uh
uh in the year there was santorum and uh
and uh mitt romney yeah oh well
so we went through it back then and we
all left and now we see him he was mr he
was a libertarian
on the war and you even look at his
arguments on drugs and you look at his
arguments on national defense and where
he was hawkish and where he wasn't
and now as a he holds very big
government views
um which again i would just say are
inconsistent with not only a
conservative viewpoint but the viewpoint
that he espoused
not that long ago here he is on the ben
shapiro show at daily wire saying that
if he were president
he would use absolute power to simply
ban uh self-driving cars
would you tucker carlson be in favor of
restrictions on the ability of trucking
companies to
use this sort of technology specifically
to you know sort of artificially
maintain the number of jobs that are
available in the trucking industry are
you joking
in a second in a second
okay but let's let's agree let's give
him a pass oh man ben has that
yeah then has that over that he has that
quality he does yeah
he was like the unibrow baby in the
simpsons
um now that might just seem like well
he's only being big government there
because he's pro-working man
right he's a protectionist just like
tariffs truckers and so some people go
made an america sticker
tucker carlson is one of us great i
understand that that's a new sort of
populist worldview i don't think it's
very consistent with
a conservative worldview however i
understand why people might maintain
that position
however there are other examples of big
government i would sort of say uh
liberal leftist authoritarian tendencies
as you see we talked about it on the
show which was pretty upsetting to me
that at that time
no longer the number one conservative
show was advocating for covid panic here
you have him
in february uh talking about predictions
of over one million deaths in the united
states and uh he actually went on to
brag that he had brought this
information to donald trump and told him
that he needed to take action sooner
than he had here's that clip
but nevertheless 70 percent of the
world's population is a big number in
fact it's
4.5.4 billion people
currently the coronavirus appears to
kill about two percent of the people who
have it
so let's be generous for a moment and
imagine that asymptomatic carriers are
not detected and the real death rate is
only say
half a percent that would be one quarter
of the current estimate
even under that scenario there would
still be 27 million deaths from
chronovirus globally
in this country more than a million
would die
does that seem like fear porn to you and
here's what's important contrast that
with what he says about the pandemic now
was there ever i was wrong because this
was keep in mind before the
completely discredited imperial college
study of london right
well if we just keep counting though we
might actually get to a million at some
point
you know if we just roll up all the blue
and hard yeah and motorcycle accidents
where you
you coughed right before you hit the
walls i mean look at you know the the
flu clearly just changed into covid
because
you know we have no flu deaths now
basically right it's amazing it's i mean
we've gotten rid of the flu we've never
been able to do that
modern stuff and here's one thing like
let's this is one thing that this is
also why we mentioned that we'll never
be doing rebuttals to the young turks
because i and i'm
this isn't really punching i don't want
to use this term but i always believe in
at least punching up people have asked
what my view is on tucker carlson
obviously tucker carlson is far more
well established than we've been at
least for a longer period of time with a
network with far more firepower
um another sort of ins some inside
baseball there are people in blacklist
if they appear on newsmax and fox news
people that's conjecture but i can tell
you what there absolutely is a black
listing with people at fox news because
i can tell you that from yours truly i
can tell you that from people here on
our network over at the blaze people who
are not allowed to appear on fox news if
it's seen as competitive
so this is not you need to understand
that fox news is not in this for some
ideology it's in it for a profit there
was a niche market where they have a
stranglehold and they're now starting to
lose that stranglehold
but you may be asking yourself some
questions why isn't this guest on fox
news why isn't that's good
he doesn't have the ability tucker does
not have the ability to host any guests
that he wants
he doesn't have the ability to appear
anywhere that he wants that's not his
fault that's the contract that he signed
right now again we look at this and okay
maybe he's looking out for the working
man when he talks about banning
self-driving cars but when combined with
the fact that he was advocating
i don't necessarily know that you would
call them draconian lockdowns but
certainly measures more severe than most
of you including tucker carlson now are
rebelling against
you would have to say there's remarkable
inconsistency when you look at someone
and say okay he was pro-iraq war until
he was against
the war in iraq you can say okay that's
a change of opinion i understand it but
then when you take it again in tandem
with what we've already gone over with
covid
and banning self-driving cars and drugs
and sidney powell
and the situation of being a libertarian
versus being a populist you go home a
second it just seems like this keeps
changing from
cnn to msnbc to fox news
pre-trump to fox news post trump and
then it seems like his views have
changed depending on whether he can get
a scoop from sydney powell or not listen
we wanted to have sydney powell on the
show we couldn't have her on my opinions
on sidney powell
have not changed our opinions on kovid
have not changed
my opinion on constitution on the
constitution of the united states and
this election
have not changed my opinion on abusing
executive powers
to simply ban something you don't like
has not changed yeah
and and i to be clear i don't we're not
punching at tucker carlson right now
we're not going after him
belabored i didn't want to do this
people are
listen the ratings have gone down
dramatically people feel as though fox
news may not be in their corner and they
don't
they don't feel as though they're
getting a straight uh a straight scoop
from people and someone who worked there
for over four years
i think that there are a lot of great
people there but you can't just
assume that some giant corporate entity
and all of their personalities by
default are on your side and do a little
digging you'll see that
not even consistent on which side
they're on yeah and in that clip he
actually said the reason that we're
reporting on it
is because it's true right and okay he
had a point there he could have done it
in a different way that's the exact same
thing that we're doing it there's a
reason we're talking about this because
these things
are true we're not saying that tucker
carlson's a bad guy should never listen
to him again
but he made some missteps here and you
need to know that that's not just a
one-off
right and these are true things and this
happens with conservatives virtue
signaling where it's like ah
look i am better than you because i'm
going to call you out even though you're
a conservative good example would be i i
i'm sure that let's say we find out it
was just some kind of a clerical error
with the voter registration my personal
voter registration which i've
said 99 chance i'm just doing it wrong
like my grandmother with a vcr
but someone coming out going actually
that's just an accidental double count
and i'm a professional analyst
and you didn't get this right therefore
you're a fraud that's what you see
lana in the conservative movement
because that wouldn't even be accurate
i've allowed room for myself to be
incredible exactly
when someone does that like you do with
sidney powell like tucker carlson did
you undercut them you undercut the
movement you undercut people who are
fighting for constitutional freedoms of
the united states and i don't see how
that benefits anyone
which is why i avoided doing this sub
doing this very topic because i think
that as a general rule
i like a world where tucker carlson
exists more than where he doesn't same
thing i have disagreements with ben
shapiro a whole lot people say well why
haven't you voiced your disagreements
with him have you seen him on the show
listen it's not always serenading with
ben
and i get that his dad was a composer
the point is
i i i prefer a world where there's ben
shapiro versus no ben shapiro right yeah
i don't agree with candace owens
but i prefer a world where there's a
candace owens as opposed to no candice
owens good for her on winning that
censorship
issue with these checkers i don't agree
with glenn beck and everything but i
prefer a worldwide i prefer a world
where there is a tucker carlson a glenn
beckham markle than a kindest owner ben
shapiro and myself
than without them however when you have
some of those people as we've seen with
tucker carlson
in several instances taking pot shots at
other people who he too should want to
see amongst our ranks
combined with the intellectual
inconsistency over time
it just rubs me the wrong way much like
al gore rubs the masseuse uh the wrong
way
or so or though if that's the wrong way
sign me up
we're going to go exclusively now by the
way two mug club take your chat and play
some hipster
hobo oh you everyone watching on youtube
right now the hundred something thousand
people just click like that's all i ask
that you do hit the like button
right now whether archived or live
youtube we don't love you piss off